what is functions as a service or faz
has this more commonly known as are fazz
and serverless the same thing
or are they different hi i'm jason with
the ibm cloud team
i'm gonna answer those questions for you
today if we go too fast please make sure
to hit that subscribe button
all right i'm excited again so let's
take a step back and look at
a time before we had cloud so back in
the day
an organization would have to manage
their whole it software stack
on premises so
let's take a look at that so at the
bottom here you'd have your hardware
and this would be all your compute your
network and your storage resources
and then moving on up we'd have our
virtualization layer
and essentially what happens here is
you'd be virtualizing all those hardware
resources with something say like a
hypervisor
to create modular virtual machines so
you could horizontally scale
and then moving on up then move into our
operating system
and i'm sure most of you are aware of
what this is
this would be the software that's
actually on your computer and enables
programs to run
and then on top of that we run into our
runtime
and this would really be the glue
between your operating system and your
application
and be the environment that your
application operates in
and then last but not least we have our
application
and this would be where all the magic
happens so this would be your business
logic right and this is where your
development team will spend most of your
time because this is where they design
build and deploy your application
so as you can see this is quite a bit
for one organization to maintain
and own you know up front you have a lot
of costs with your hardware
and you're not very agile say something
goes down in this it stack here
i mean it could affect any of these
given layers and the time for revision
and get your application out the door
could take anywhere from a week to even
a month
so not very efficient so let's fast
forward to the early 2000s
and aws emerged of a new cloud computing
service model
which is infrastructure has a service
also known as is
and what is does it actually abstracts
these lower layers
these infrastructure layers which you
can now run from a cloud service
provider
and it's a common model used today so
it's much more cost efficient without
having to own and maintain these layers
and you can revision and get your
application outdoor much quicker so
we're looking at anything from
an hour to minutes which is a huge
increase from that
month to week timeline
so then we also had another cloud
computing service model emerge which is
platform has a service
and as you can see we even took that
abstraction level even further with pass
so with this model now you're just
worried about your application that's
all you have to maintain
and the idle time is much shorter too so
you'd be running at least one server but
you don't have to worry about your
runtime your operating system just that
application
and the time to provision and get your
application outdoor is much shorter as
well so you're looking anything from
minutes
to seconds
all right so you're probably wondering
okay so we're at the application layer
how can we
abstracting further well let me explain
so back in 2014 hook.io
emerged of a new cloud computing service
model which is the topic of the hour
and that is functions has a service also
known as faz
and what faz does it abstracts that
application
so now you can only focus on the
functions
and the functions are the individual
components that actually make up
that application so it'd be the
individual tasks
you know something like uploading an
image file
you just have so much more flexibility
and you have
zero idle times you don't even need a
server that's all managed and taken care
for you
by the cloud service provider it's much
more cost effective
and the time to revision with function
as service is
lightning fast so we're looking at
anywhere from a second
to millisecond
so i know i went through this pretty
quick but hopefully you can get a sense
of how
functions as a service relates to the
other cloud computing service models
within this landscape
oh i'm sorry i should actually take a
step back we should talk about software
as a service briefly so that's another
cloud computing service model
that actually abstracts all these layers
here including the functions
and you know that would be something
like youtube if you're watching this
video that would be an example of
software as a service
so now let's take a look at how
functions as a service relates to
serverless
and take a look at the architecture
all right so functions as a service is
actually a key subset of serverless
as well as backing as a service backend
as a service is any third party service
that you integrate with your application
and the great thing about is there's no
code that you need to manage and there's
no servers
so let's take a look at what a
serverless application architecture
might look like
and let's use an example of something oh
i don't know let's say
a hair color for gray hair ecommerce
storefronts
which i've never looked into before
okay so we'll start here for our client
and this would be our hair color
ecommerce website and let's say we have
a user
and they click and they want to see some
before and after images so
we would have a request come down here
and we would have a third party object
storage service
and the great thing about this is there
is no
servers involved once again so this
would be one example of backing as a
service
and it would use something like html uh
it could be javascript or css
and it would actually send those images
back to the client
so now that they've looked at some
before and after images now we need to
get them authenticated
so we can again have another third party
service integrated
and we could have this as an
authentication service
okay so this would be one more example
of back in as a service but now let's
let's take a look at functions as a
service
and let's say that the client needs to
get their account so we'd have another
request come and this would interact
with what we call an
api gateway
and this api gateway would then invoke
a function
and we'll call this function git
account and this get account function
will now
communicate with a different database
and this would be
customer
database
so this would be our functions as a
service right here so this would be one
individual task within
the greater application
so let's do another one say the client
makes another request and now they want
to see
you know what kind of hair color options
they they're working with right
so we'd have another request go through
the api gateway
and this would have another individual
function
and this would be available
if i could spell color
okay so this function available color
would go to a separate database
and we'll call this color database
color db
all right so this is again just a very
simplified
view into a serverless application
architecture
and i mainly want to focus in on the
function as a service
functions right here so let's just zoom
in right now and we'll look at the api
gateway
and our functions and expand
and expand this out as well the api
gateway
so api gateway it translates requests to
a single endpoint and routes it to a
different functions as service function
so in our case our user makes requests
right so we have git
api
color this api gateway notices requests
and it sees available color function
over here
because it has the available color route
within the api gateway
so again functions as a service is
essentially a small piece of code run by
developer that are executing the cloud
and run on stateless containers and what
this means is that they do their job
and then they disappear and this leads
me to my first key benefit i want to
highlight
which is you only pay for do you use
because unlike our other cloud computing
service models if you recall you always
got to pay for some idle time
even if platform is serviced you're
responsible for at least one single
server
another key benefit is you could just
focus on that code
right so without the underlying
infrastructure which is going to be a
common theme
you know throughout this whole video is
you could just focus on those individual
functions
from splitting up that server and that
business logic where you don't have to
worry about maintaining it with that
underlying infrastructure
another key benefit is auto scaling
so again without that infrastructure you
can scale on demand
automatically and instantaneously right
so if your function service platform
has demand go down it'll automatically
scale down for you
and then last but not least highlight i
want to mention is it's inherently
highly available
so by being spread across multiple
availability zones in different
geographical regions
you can deploy your function service
platform in those different regions
at no incremental cost
so i know this is just a quick overview
of functions service but hopefully you
can now see some of the key benefits
as well as how it relates to serverless
and other cloud computing service models
thank you if you have questions please
drop us a line below
if you want to see more videos like this
in the future please like and subscribe
and don't forget you can grow your
skills and earn a badge with ibm cloud
labs
which are free browser-based interactive
kubernetes labs